el magnate estadounidense jeff bezos
fundador de amazon y considerado el
hombre más rico del planeta está a punto
de ir a el espacio a bordo del cohete
new zipper de blue origin será un viaje
fugaz de 11 minutos y lo hará a una
velocidad de 3 mil 700 kilómetros por
hora
y triplicando la velocidad del sonido la
cápsula está diseñada para transportar a
seis personas pero en este vuelo
inaugural solo van cuatro además de efe
pesos ir a su hermano marc pesos un
bombero voluntario wali funk de 82 años
y una de las mujeres piloto que fue al
espacio en el mercury 13 de la nasa en
la década de los 60 y por último oliver
temen un joven de 18 años que acaba de
graduarse de secundaria y que se ha
costeado el viaje ninguno de los cuatro
tripulantes llevará el traje de
astronauta y en su lugar utilizarán una
vestimenta estándar azulada conocida
como flash
schütz que es mucho más liviana y
controlable la cama la carrera por
encabezar el sector del turismo espacial
ha comenzado hace nueve días el magnate
y filántropo richard branson hacía lo
propio desde el aeropuerto espacial
space port en el desierto de nuevo
méxico con su compañía
galactic el británico ha insistido en
varias ocasiones que esto no es una
competición sino una manera de
contribuir al sector aerospacial a
diferencia del vuelo de virgin galactic
cuya aeronave despegó como un avión el
de blue origin se lanzará verticalmente
hacia el espacio